- [Voiceover] Alright I'll tackle.
In the last video we did
the first part of part A,
now, so the second part of part A.
So, the second part of part A,
they say, "Calculate the
number of moles of ethene
that would be produced if
the dehydration reaction
went to completion".
Well, this is the dehydration
reaction right over here,
and they're telling us,
they're telling us that we start
with 0.200 grams
of ethanol,
so, if we start with
0.200 grams of ethanol,
and if we figure out how many
moles of ethanol that is,
well, for every mole of ethanol,
if we have the reaction go to,
if the dehydration reaction
goes to completion,
for every mole of ethanol
that we start with,
we're going to have a mole of ethene,
and a mole of water.
So, if we can just figure out
how many moles of ethanol this is,
then we'll say, "Okay, if
this were completely react,
we would have that many moles of ethene".
So, let's figure this out.
So if we say,
so, we have ethanol,
so for ethanol,
we are starting with zero
.200 grams,
and we wanna convert this to moles,
so we wanna multiply this times,
we want grams in the denominator
to cancel out with this grams,
and moles in the numerator.
So, one mole of ethanol is,
as a mass of how many grams,
well, they tell us that
earlier on the problem,
they say, "Ethanol,
molar mass 46.1 grams per mol",
so, ethanol, molar mass
of 46.1 grams per mol,
or another way to thinking about it,
one mole would have mass of 46.1 grams
of 46.1 grams,
and so if we do this, we are going to get
0.200 over
46.1,
and then grams cancel with the grams,
and that going to be
how many moles we have,
and this is going to be equal to,
we have three significant digits
that we're gonna be with
three significant digits
divided by three significant digits,
so this is going to be
all right, so we clear this,
so .2, I could write 00,
but it's going to,
for the calculator's purposes
this is the same thing,
divided by 46.1 is equal to
0.0043,
I want three significant figures here,
so 43 I'm gonna round up, 434,
.00434
so 0.00434
moles.
So, we've seen so far,
if the ethanol were
(mumbling) the reaction,
if we have this many moles of ethanol,
well, and if they completely react,
well, then we should end up
with that many moles of ethene,
and so if we have,
if it we get a dehydration,
I'm gonna write it this way,
if dehydration
dehydration reaction
goes to completion
every
every mole of ethanol
would be converted
to a mole of ethene
and a mole of water.
I shouldn't write the shorthand there,
a mole, if I'm writing it out,
mole of and a mole water.
So 0.00434
mole of ethanol
would
yield,
that same number of moles,
0.00434
moles of ethene.
So, if the reaction went to completion
that how many moles it would produce.
What we actually measure is
a smaller number than that,
so the reaction didn't
go fully to completion.
So now let's tackle part B,
let's tackle part B, and they ask us,
"Calculate he percent yield
of ethene in the experiment".
Well, the percent yield is
going to be how much we got,
divide by how much we
would ideally have gotten
if the reaction went fully to completion.
So yield
yield is going to be equal
to how much we actually got,
which we figured out in part one,
so 0.00264
moles over what we
actually got, i'm sorry,
what we actually got over
what we'd have ideally gotten
if the reaction went to completion,
so divided by
0.00434
moles,
and this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to
so, 00264
divided by
00434, is equal to,
and let's see, we have three
significant digits here,
so 60, I can say .608,
or I could say 60.8% yield.
So, I'm gonna write this as
actually this is gonna, I'm rounding,
so I can say 60.8% yield,
and there you go.